MMM!
THAT'S GOT A GOOD TASTE.
THAT'S--THAT'S A LOT
TO DO A SHOT.
- YOU'RE INSANE!
WHOO!
- YEAH, WE SHOULD'VE
JUST SIPPED THAT.
- WHOO!
- READY?
- OKAY, BUDDY.
ELVIS WRITES A LETTER TO NIXON
WHILE ON THE PLANE.
THEY LAND, AND HE DROPS IT OFF
AT THE FRONT OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT WAS SHOCKING.
NO CELEBRITIES WANT
TO HANG OUT WITH NIXON.
SO WHEN HE REACHED OUT,
THEY'RE LIKE,
ELVIS WANTS TO MEET WITH YOU.
THIS CAN'T HURT MATTERS.
DON'T YOU WANNA SEE
WHAT ELVIS HAS TO SAY?
WHY NOT?
HE'S LIKE, YEAH, ARRANGE IT.
YEAH, I WANNA MEET HIM.
LET'S SEE WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND ELVIS COMES IN.
AND NIXON LOOKS AT HIM
LIKE, UH,
THIS IS CRAZY, MAN.
YOU DRESS REALLY CRAZY, MAN.
HE'S LIKE, HEY,
YOU HAVE YOUR GET-UP,
I HAVE MINE, OKAY?
NIXON'S LIKE,
YEAH, I'M GLAD YOU CAME BY.
I WANTED TO MEET YOU,
AND GOOD TO SEE YOU.
AND ELVIS DOES
THE HARD SELL THING.
HE NEEDS THE BADGE.
WELL, I CARE, MAN.
I CARE ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THESE PEOPLE.
AND I CARE ABOUT THE HIPPIES,
AND EVERYTHING THAT'S
BEING SAID RIGHT NOW, MAN.
IT'S TERRIFYING.
PEOPLE THAT ARE SAYING
THINGS ABOUT YOU
AND, UH, THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE SAYING THINGS ABOUT ME.
AND THAT'S WHY I'M HAPPY
TO BE HERE...MAN.
BUT I NEED THIS BADGE.
THIS IS SO BIG FOR ME.
I NEED IT.
AND NIXON REALLY TAKES IT IN,
KINDA ASKS HIS AIDE.
HE'S LIKE, CAN WE DO THIS?
AND THE AIDE COMES BACK, SAYS,
I'M SORRY, IT'S DONE.
WE CANNOT GIVE THIS BADGE.
SORRY, MR. PRESLEY, WE CANNOT--
YOU HAVE NO QUALIFICATIONS
IN OUR MIND TO HAVE THIS BADGE.
[burps]
MM.
SORRY, BROTHER.
I'M LOVIN' IT.
AND NIXON DECIDES
TO GIVE HIM THIS BADGE.
SO ELVIS GOES BACK
TO GET PHOTOS TAKEN,
BUT THEN ELVIS IS
A LICENSED AND REGISTERED
FEDERAL NARCOTICS AGENT.